[Musique]
le corps humain vu de l'intérieur
sans la maîtrise des rayons x
cette vue inestimable c'était possible
[Musique]
or il aura fallu patienter près de cent
trente ans pour que le noir et blanc
cette sa place à la couleur voici donc
la première radiographie couleurs en
trois dimensions un poignet et ça montre
plus clair plus précis les détails
anatomiques sont parfaitement définis
une fois le membre scanner on y
distingue clairement la différence entre
l'os et le muscle et le cartilage même
la position et la taille d'une tumeur
peuvent être observés de quoi aider le
médecin à poser un diagnostic plus
précis
[Musique]
la technologie à la base de cette
première a été développée au cern
à l'origine elle permettait de suivre la
trajectoire des particules celles
produites au grand accélérateur de
particules le fameux est lâché celui là
même qui a permis de découvrir le boson
de higgs en 2012 après dix ans de
recherche des scientifiques néo
zélandais sont parvenus à intégrer cette
technologie à la radiographie médicale
baptisé mais d'ipbx la technologie
fonctionne comme l'appareil photo qu'on
ajoute à un scanner à l'aide de puces de
lecture le dispositif d'imagerie détecte
les particules dès qu'elle percute la
surface d'un pixel la somme des
collisions permet alors de générer des
images à très haute résolution
chaque niveau d'énergie des rayons x est
représenté par une couleur et s'est
dégradée ces énergies varie en fonction
des parties du corps humain rencontrer
comme la grèce l'eau et le calcium salué
les premiers résultats laisse présager
un avenir prometteur pour la
radiographie médicale couleurs avant
toute chose
elle devra d'abord faire l'objet
d'essais cliniques
le premier essai débutera sous peu en
nouvelle zélande sur des patients suivis
en orthopédie et rhumatologie et qui
sait si tout se déroule bien
le noir et blanc prendra des couleurs
[Musique]